so what were you talking about what the
valadis didn't know [ __ ] with family
Holly should I know is that their
[ __ ] rich and ballin out of their
mind
what are you I guarantee luck because
they she got caught cheating or whatever
he got caught cheating it's gonna be
even juicier vlogs everyone is gonna
want to tune in yeah now it's good it's
good now it's like cheating people
Kardashian stuff right it's like I was I
wasn't watching this or anything but
apparently Tristan Thompson cheated on
one of the Kardashians which which
Kardashian is he with uh the taller one
what's the one that looks like a
completely different person after her 17
surgeries to her face all of them but
still very similar didn't Caitlyn Jenner
get woman of the year or something like
yeah that shit's tight dude women must
been really somebody she hit somebody at
her car Caitlyn Jenner did yeah and then
she turned and then she got the surgery
and then nothing really happened after
because they could have find the guy
that did he was an Olympic gold medalist
and track yeah no but everybody was
saying because that whole situation I
was watching the episode with my lady
last night cuz she watches the
Kardashian show and in my head I'm like
dude they're making so much money just
often obviously maybe whether it was
planned or not I don't I don't know if
it is or whatever well that's when
people get super mad about this she did
this whole [ __ ] where she has this new
makeup line called kimono right and I
think she was trying troll to she's
trying to copyright the word kimono or
some [ __ ] or Brandon that is hers but
she's clearly not stupid you know she
did that just so he could create a bunch
of like fervor so people could talk
about it and you know that's how she's
been doing her whole business model her
whole life right and so people were
[ __ ] upset they're like how [ __ ]
you know a lot of you know Asian people
came out the woodwork
they're just you know what how dare you
[ __ ] like yell people like come on
she's not dumb you know she's doing this
on purpose right she clearly knows that
kimono is a Japanese thing right right
and so you know I'd be a trending topic
as people ice-crazy how people fall into
it so easily
ya know it's like it's so obvious like
they're just trying to create a [ __ ]
buzz it's crazy that they give a [ __ ]
about this high school as [ __ ] in
the first place like I don't I got bills
and [ __ ] like I don't care if that
cheated on her and [ __ ] you should
because it's really important it was
very hurtful or okay but yeah like you
you watch it and then in your head that
was like the season finale of course it
was the season finale it was set up it
was hooked up all the way until the 16th
episode
sure enough does he find out where he's
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] yeah and oh the NBA
player that's on the road [ __ ] 200
days out of the year is banging other
chicks no way who says when it's so
interesting because I think when people
don't see reality TV like nobody would
realize that reality TV is in reality TV
right they have producers they have
writers they chop it up and they make it
look a certain way and they always like
[ __ ] people up with it I talked about
this on the last podcast too like I I
did this thing where I talked about a
comedian who I don't think is that funny
right but I wanted to preface it with
some nice [ __ ] cuz I don't want to talk
about other people's comedy when I'm not
even doing stand-up myself right now so
Who am I to say back to say it as a as a
person who likes comedy right as just as
a fan and so I'd simply just stated that
I watch Brendan Schaub special and that
I think it's funny but what it came out
was just me trashing you know about
trashing ready
you had to come out on well but you know
I think with the way he got chopped up
it made it sound like I was somebody
that was critiquing his comedy and it
wasn't the case I just thought it was
early for him to do a huge special cuz
he just started yeah yeah exactly and
then he got gassed up by Joe Rogan and
you know he does the thing with Theo von
so I think him for myself mentally I
expect him to be on the same level as
them right yeah and so when I saw his
special I was like he's weren't
you're expecting a lot more yeah so what
the [ __ ] is this yeah did you watch it I
did not watch it and our Showtime
no it's a matter with you man we're
sponsored by Showtime well I'm not but
David is we're not here